[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí en
france 24 mi nombre es liliana valencia
pese a su acelerada campaña de
vacunación los gobiernos europeos temen
una cuarta oleada de kobe 19 ocasionada
principalmente por la variante delta que
podría llegar a ser dominante a nivel
mundial la organización mundial de la
salud ha dicho que está variante ya está
en 14 países de las américas para
analizar este tema saludamos al doctor
oscar franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y de la universidad
erasmo de rotterdam y también asesor
científico de france 24 bienvenidos
nuevamente autor y cuéntenos con el
lento ritmo de vacunación en américa
latina' que tan dominante puede volverse
la variante delta en esta región
si miramos la clasificación de la
organización mundial de la salud hay
tres categorías de variantes la primera
es alta consecuencia segunda es
preocupación la tercera es interés
dentro de las variantes de preocupación
está la alfa la beta la gama y la delta
y de estas cuatro la de alta la más
peligrosa porque es la más contagiosa
porque suele presentarse como un
resfriado dolor de garganta o dolor de
cabeza se defiende muy bien contra las
defensas por la infección ósea que puede
causar la infección y entonces por esto
por este acúmulo de condiciones hace que
la variante de venta sea de mucho
peligro de mucho riesgo no solamente en
latinoamérica sino a nivel mundial bueno
pero también cuéntenos cómo responde la
variante delta a las vacunas actuales
principalmente las que están en américa
latina haciendo inoculadas
se han visto con datos del reino unido
que una sola 12 de facer puede proteger
solamente hasta un 33 por ciento una
eficacia de 33 por ciento mientras que
dos dosis llega aproximadamente al 70%
en estos días recibimos datos de israel
donde se ve que la eficacia de fallecer
con dos dosis para prevenir la infección
es de un 64 por ciento entonces lo que
estamos viendo es que es importante
tener las dos dosis también hay
información con la variante con vacunas
como astrazéneca y como jansen pero
todas indican que protegen contra
hospitalización y contra mortalidad pero
aún se puede presentar la infección
bueno ama la situación actual de américa
latina creado usted podría explicarse
por la variante delta por la presencia
que ya hay en las naciones que
hablábamos en un principio esta
entrevista
lo que hemos visto en los últimos meses
la catástrofe que está ocurriendo en
toda américa latina yo creo que se puede
explicar más por otras variantes como la
variante gamma que la variante de brasil
que empezó en manaus y también por la
variante lambda o la variante andina que
fue detectada por primera vez en agosto
en perú y estas dos variantes han pasado
a afectar todo el continente a afectar
toda la región suramericana y el
problema que tenemos en suramérica es
que no tenemos suficiente vigilancia
genómica entonces no sabemos realmente
qué tanto están presentes lambda y gamma
delta está apareciendo y ahora la
pregunta es qué va a pasar con delta
cuando se enfrente contra estas otras
variantes y si va a causar una
catástrofe similar a lo que ocurrió en
indio bueno llamadas con esto que usted
nos cuenta cuéntenos cómo podemos hacer
para prepararlos para prevenir y mayores
contagios causados por las variantes que
estamos viendo
las medidas son las mismas la higiene el
uso de tapabocas material del
distanciamiento y muy importante
aplicarse la vacuna debemos recordar que
la variante delta como las otras
variantes responden a las vacunas y por
lo tanto es tan importante aplicarse el
programa completo de vacunación no
solamente una dosis sino dos dosis en
los casos en los que es recomendado
bueno pues agradecemos a todos y todas
franco por estar una vez más aquí en
france24 nuestro mejor científico y
también ustedes por continuar en nuestra
sintonía nos vemos más adelante con más
información quédense con nosotros
[Música]